- Is there ever a song
that you wanna play though
because it's like one
of your favorite covers?
Like, before you had all your hits,
you know, when you go on stage
and you have to play like,
you know?
- Mm.
- You have so many hits you
don't think covers now but-
- No, we do.
We love to play covers.
- [Kelly] I do too.
- We've been so lucky with
people we get to do covers with-
- Yeah?
- And that's when we,
when there's a special moment
or a city we're in where
a cover feels right,
or a person who's there that
we wanna ask to come on stage.
- Yeah.
- My number one, probably,
is Michael J. Fox came and
played two of the songs
from "Back to the Future" with us.
- What?
- In MetLife Stadium and that-
- Oh my God!
- That was really wonderful.
- Yeah!
- And then another thing in Argentina,
so it happened a few places
but him coming to play "Johnny B. Goode"
and stuff that was wonderful.
- Oh my God!
I remember that from that film.
I thought it was so cool.
- Yeah.
- That's what made me wanna-
- Be in a band, you know, that-
- Really?
- That scene. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- When, some of you are probably too young
to remember that film but-
- No, I even remember him,
I remember the whole thing.
- Okay.
- You're gonna love this.
You got to listen to this
and he's in the back and he's playing-
- Yeah.
- I remember the whole thing.
- I love that.
And what a random way to be inspired.
Like nobody would have
probably guessed that.
That was the thing that kind
of like really wanted you-
- Yeah, I mean-
- [Kelly] To make you, that's so cool.
- I grew up in real
farmland of England before-
- Yeah.
- Before the internet.
- I grew up in a real random farmland too,
in Texas.
- Yeah.
- So yeah.
There was nothing-
- So any music on TV,
the first thing I ever recorded was,
there was a show called the "The A-Team."
- Oh, yeah.
- And I had a cassette recorder
and held it against the TV
to record the theme tune.
- Oh, I would, that-
- That's my first-
- I used to press play in record
while the radio was playing
'cause I was too poor-
- Yeah.
- To actually buy music,
'cause I had no money.
And I was like, I
learned it from a friend,
I was like, "Now!"
And I'd be like, "DJ, shut up!"
I'm like, you don't want
the DJ, they'd talk over it
and you're like, "Shut up!"
- Yeah.
- Anyway.
But now I love to buy
music and support music.
(audience applauding)